on verra bonjour alors après ses
déclarations de washington et des pays
de l'otan la russie a réagi
bonjour olivier oui tout à fait la
russie n'exclut pas que l'ukraine avec
le soutien de l'occident décide de
s'engager dans une aventure militaire a
déclaré le chef de la diplomatie russe
sergueï lavrov il dit quand même espérer
que les autorités de kiev ne se
lanceront pas dans une opération à
l'instar de l'ex président géorgien
mikheil saakashvili en août 2008 quand
ce dernier avait attaqué l'ossétie du
sud je vous propose d'écouter
tout cela menace directement la sécurité
de la russie le président poutine en a
parlé le 18 novembre lors d'une réunion
élargie de notre ministère et il a
souligné que nous n'avons pas besoin de
conflits mais si l'occident ne parvient
pas à retenir l'ukraine ou si al'inverse
ils l'encouragent nous prendrons bien
sûr toutes les mesures nécessaires pour
assurer une sécurité efficace de notre
pays
le ministre des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov intervient aujourd'hui au
conseil de la fédération de russie
chambre haute du parlement russe avec un
discours au sujet des priorités de la
politique extérieure russe il doit
ensuite également répondre aux questions
des sénateurs ainsi que des journalistes
merci beaucoup verra pour toutes ces
précisions verhaeghe hoffman en direct
depuis mosson